foreign
live stream of Call of Duty 4 the the
remastered Modern Warfare uh we're just
playing the single player today that's
all that's available currently uh in
fact we have Early Access right now like
this isn't publicly available yet um
we're able to play a couple days early
just because we're lucky
um so we're gonna play with the single
player but just to start out uh the way
that you play this is actually a little
bit complicated so if you digitally
purchase the game if you digitally
purchase infinite Warfare the next Call
of Duty that comes out November 4th uh
you will gain early access to the
remaster but you have to actually
purchase the game you have to purchase
the digital Deluxe Legacy Pro or digital
Legacy versions of the downloadable full
infinite Warfare game like you can't
even this doesn't even come with a pre a
pre-order it comes with like a
pre-purchase so if you give Activision
money they will then allow you to
download and play the remaster a month
early that's insane to me it's a little
it's a little odd and then a month from
now uh if you actually buy the game on
disc if you walk into a brick and mortar
store and you buy a physical copy of the
game uh you will then be able to play
the downloaded version of Modern Warfare
only if you have the disc in the system
at the time like the the game will not
run the remaster will not run unless you
have infinite Warfare in your system uh
which is a little bit crazy uh because
the game isn't like we just spent all
morning downloading 40 gigs of the
remaster which is a pretty impressively
large file so I'm excited to see how
this looks I mean a big part of this
place
looks like as far as I know there have
been no content changes it's all about
remastered visuals remastered sound
maintaining the sound weapons and
movements and everything that kind of
made the contain what it is um
today but yeah kind of it's
the purchasing structure is a little bit
weird I guess maybe you're just supposed
to think of it as you know an incentive
it's a bonus for buying the game it's
not really its own product it's purely
just you know something extra for people
who buy the next upcoming game but I I'm
not sure I mean I think that's how
activation sees it I'm not convinced
that that's how fans see it I feel like
that's a slap to the people who did this
remaster because I'm looking at it there
looks really good it looks really good
it looks really really cool so there's
price uh like at the time we had no idea
he was gonna be around for so long
become like this big huge part of the
franchise it's so cool I kind of forgot
that he's like I'm a Call of Duty Modern
Warfare StoryBots like I like the story
of Modern Warfare also John Luke is
playing this is John Luke psyche I'm
Scott Butterworth we should have
introduced ourselves at the top probably
but that's not important what's
important is the Call of Duty remaster
exactly Modern Warfare remaster
um so hopefully it's that whole big
explanation of how you can actually play
this makes sense
um so yeah go if you're really
interested in playing this game early
um go ahead and pre-purchase any of
those digital versions that I mentioned
at the top
um if you want to wait for a box copy of
infinite Warfare you can do that as well
man no honor yeah all right I've already
lost myself uh that is one of the sort
of the problems with um this way that
this campaign is structured like it's
very forward moving so if you stop
paying attention it's kind of like oh
I'm lost in the level for a minute wait
you used to have the the markers you are
100 200. forgive me I haven't played
this game in
you and everyone else yeah it's been uh
so yeah the game originally came out uh
so modern warfare came out November 2007
so they're actually a year ahead of
their 10-year anniversary uh I feel like
it's almost would have made more sense
uh there was another game that also was
like a year ahead that was interesting I
think Bioshock right yes Bioshock
collection was uh you're ahead of the
10-year anniversary of the original
Bioshock I'm fairly certain yes it was
are you sure
it was no Bioshock 2007. all right so
yeah they're a year early who knows man
the nine year anniversary the 2007 was
such a good year oh it really was
um because that was also the Europe
um
before there was rocket League there was
rock band that was like back when I
worked at old magazines man like every
day after work be like all right guys
rock band room let's do it
uh yes let's see I'm keeping an eye on
chat by the way so if you are in our
twitch chat or if you are watching on
our site or on YouTube I will be trying
to keep an eye in the chat there are a
lot of them so chat's been pretty
quickly but I'm gonna try to keep up I'm
gonna try to answer them
move up
stairs clear yeah we see that oh yeah
you have the game are you in a headset
oh yeah oh yeah okay
yeah I mean this game like the campaign
a lot of the ideas that have now become
almost complete shooters were really
established by Modern Warfare like this
idea of the you know your radio buddy
compelling you through each level and
just like the energy and the momentum of
the campaign the way that it's all
structured a lot of that was established
by Modern Warfare so it's really cool to
go back and kind of see where a lot of
this started and also like I love that
this game switched protagonist so many
times then had all these different
characters to focus on and it allowed
them to do crazy things like Nuke one of
their main characters like to me the
most memorable moment from this campaign
well not only that I think a lot of the
things that uh you look at now that Call
of Duty does uh sort of like these big
moments and killing its characters and
it all feels sort of like a little bit
expected yeah uh back when this came out
that was all new yeah it was it was kind
of mind-blowing like the again the
structure of like it's very set piece
driven
um there's all kinds of chaos there's
all kinds of yeah like just little
moments like that yeah throughout the
campaign to break up the
moment-to-moment shooting there's just
like little unexpected things and then
obviously the bigger moments like the
nuke or even like really memorable
entire missions like late in the game we
were talking about this before we
started streaming the all gillied up
Mission which by the way is a terrible
name I didn't know the name of that
mission until we looked it up before the
stream but if you remember playing this
Captain Price the sniper mission that
happens late in the game is it's called
all gillied up but there's so many
missions like that that it's like this
very distinct take on the gameplay like
it's like you sneaking through a level
having to take one shot and make your
way out like at the time that was really
weird for Shooters the fact that it
wasn't just like here's a bunch of guys
in a room go kill them there's plenty of
that as well but the fact that there
were so many missions that broke away
from that room again at the time just
crazy and super memorable oh yeah so I
mean I I can understand why so many
people were excited about the remaster I
think possibly more excited about this
than they are about infinite Warfare to
be completely honest it kind of makes me
wonder if that's why you're right there
doing it the way that our Activision is
because they want to incentivize people
to
they they know people want this maybe
more than the other ones so they want to
use it as a way to get people to buy oh
totally no they're totally incentivizing
people to buy infinite Warfare which I
mean yeah of course they are I mean
there's nothing necessarily wrong with
that I mean again if you're just looking
at this as a pre-order bonus then it
makes sense I mean it is kind of a shame
that it's not just its own independent
product but I wouldn't be shot nice
crotch shot
that's why you don't come charge it
around cover guys oh that guy went
flying
this looks awesome by the way I'm going
to circle back to our conversation but
this looks so great like I love the
particle effects I love like the smoke
effects coming off the gun as you fire
the water look at the water the water on
the barrel like the reflections look
really good it's like a modern video
game it really looks like it could have
come out like a year or two ago as
opposed to nine years ago okay so Raven
software who's been a long time
contributor to the to the franchise he's
done a lot of work I know Sony works out
oh really
um yeah they have been doing stuff for
Call of Duty like on the side for a very
long time so they're not they're not in
they're not um Treyarch you know they're
not Infinity Ward but they have been
there working on this franchise for a
very long time and they have clearly
done a really excellent job with this
I'll also say that sound effects sounds
super Punchy like the guns all sound
really good right in the ass yep that's
not the that's not how you want to die
is the least dignified death
this is where things get really gnarly
oh it's gonna be so good
charted uh a friend of mine was watching
me and he noticed that I always shot
people in the crotch twice and he's like
dude why do you keep shooting people
across I don't even realize I was doing
this so apparently I have like
instinctiveness why do you hate practice
[Music]
things we never wanted to know Circle
back like I said it was going to I would
honestly be shocked if this wasn't
available as an independent download at
some point I mean we received we've
received no indication that that's ever
gonna happen but like come on just it it
just makes sense
um when the remastered launches it's
actually only going to have 10 of the 16
total multiplayer maps
um they're going to add the remaining
six as free DLC before the end of the
year so clearly they want people to hang
on to their copies of infinite Warfare
so they can continue to play the
remaster and play the new maps as they
come but once the year is out once all
the maps are available
the remaster that is wasn't available as
a separate purchases a standalone
product who knows I mean again we've
received no indication but you know
fingers crossed it just kind of makes
sense
yeah lifespan the multiplayer mode for
this will last longer or have more
people playing
I think it's gonna be a lot of people
well I mean especially early on people
are going to be really curious to go
back and believe that experience and
relive the very early because I mean
again just like the single player
established a lot of tropes that became
commonplacement and standard realistic
Shooters multiple related to detaching
thing right like it was really the first
shooter that I can remember that
introduced like leveling an XP and
ranking
remember that being really revolutionary
like wanting to rank up and wanting to
game XP by playing multiplayer I mean
prior to that we had stuff like you know
um Counter-Strike tribes and things that
were just you know get into an arena you
shoot a bunch of people they die you
play again there was no real progression
to it even if there were customization
unlocks oh you made it I didn't think
you were gonna make it oh
still awesome I was nervous for a second
that's still such a great opening level
what a great metaphor too like price
following you into the chopper
the ship sinking in the background which
actually does look pretty good by the
way
it doesn't look quite as good as the
moment to move gameplay but like a dated
cutscene is pretty hard to update and
that that looks pretty good I'm sure
that
um good job by the way you actually
played through that pretty well I'm sure
that infinite Warfare will still
probably looks better just because it is
a modern game that's built from the
ground up but I think
this looks really good
uh yeah I'm but for me it's like the
multiplayer
it is going to be Modern Warfare
multiplayers it'll be more simplistic
people have Nostalgia for that
Simplicity for those original Maps I
think people I think initially obviously
more people would be playing infinite
Warfare just because more people have it
the size of it but if this eventually
does become you know available to
download I'm kind of curious if in the
long run
this I could see this having a steady
stream of people playing it for a longer
period of time and like maybe infinite
Warfare will have more of a drop off no
potentially it will it will certainly be
interesting to see I need something to
keep an eye on but I imagine both I mean
to be honest I'm somewhat excited about
infinite Warfare I mean I know that we
get a new Call of Duty every year and
people are kind of down on the franchise
for being an annualized series but I
don't know Space Battles space dog
fighting I'm intrigued if nothing else I
want to play it I want to give it a shot
oh man this mission
right I have a feeling we're gonna be
saying that a lot there's gonna be a lot
of like ah this Mission oh there's so
many more
yeah so this you're playing the uh the
president who
posed with his status well what's cool
is like this is from what I remember a
lot of this level it's like a car ride
and you can just look around and this is
like the opening credit sequence in a
way like I think this is when like
produced by all that stuff pops up as
well so what a cool way to handle your
um your intro right I mean instead of
just having like a static screen of like
names doing it this very cinematic way
of allowing you to like look around and
experience the world while you're
getting sort of you get Exposition in
the process of the game being
interviewed this looks so good
this does look a lot I mean what's funny
is I feel like we remember games looking
better than they actually looked at the
time
um but this this holds up to my memory
which is saying a lot given that we tend
to remember oh I can just tell this car
already has way more detail than it
would have been impossible yes look at
the background see look at like the the
weathering on the seats
like the light glinting off of the
bullet hanging from the rearview mirror
a little on the nose there guys driving
the car
hey man they gotta let you know
and wouldn't that be great it was like
gunpowder ah the smell of gunpowder I'm
gonna go to Cabela's later today and
find the bullet air freshener oh no
that guy's dead a lot of dead people
uh we are playing on PS4 by the way if
anybody's curious we're currently
playing on Playstation 4.
um although obviously it's just coming
to Xbox One as well and PC
um so don't feel left out we just happen
to get codes for Playstation 4 so that's
what we're playing
somebody in the chat said I'm Scottish
Talent forever
someone else said call of ass which I
believe is a totally separate franchise
unrelated
porno bee called ass or ass of Duty
uh although I don't know I wouldn't want
to be on my area of expertise we're
outside of my wheelhouse here
we'll be sure to do a whole uh porn
parody stream sometime in the future
that's gotta be a thing right porn
parody games
uh I mean there's that well not a game
but there is a OverWatch foreign
[Music]
military coups third yeah that was
another thing this was like such a
topical game at the time and I remember
there was a lot of
um people people were actually concerned
about the switch from Call of Duty's
Roots as a World War II franchise to
focusing on Modern you know ripped from
the headlines military stories that was
an unusual thing that was an unusual
move from a franchise to so drastically
Rebrand itself I definitely remember
some people being a little angry at this
game it definitely has its own political
message you know to say like there's
there's definitely it doesn't get too
heavy-handed but I I could see some
people like it definitely has a
statement to say about America and maybe
like the way America handles Foreign
Affairs and at times I mean if nothing
else it's interesting and appreciated
that they bother to Broach topics that
are at least topical And Timely yeah I
actually I think
I kept somewhat decent job at it
honestly for like a video game like I'm
not saying it's like amazing or anything
but I feel like Call of Duty's gotten a
little more like raw raw America over
the years but this one I think was a
little more raw and a little more just
kind of it just had its own story to
tell it didn't feel preachy it was just
this one two especially two two gets
really cynical at times you remember too
the villain is in a is an American
General oh that's right and then you
have to like stab him at the end and
there's the helicopter scene yeah I
remember all that on two just has a
there's an entire level of two that's
just a reverse version of uh The Rock
oh this is super gnarly by the way I
always thought this was crazy I was like
he's not nothing bad's gonna happen here
so yeah you're playing as the character
gets shot in the face and it's just
there as a story moment it's just there
to like unsettle you as a player which
is so gnarly like that's such a cool
thing to do in a game like you have this
whole like semi-unplayable mission where
it culminates in you being executed like
a gun being pointed in your face first
person
in less than three hours that's nuts man
and then of course now we're just like
yeah whatever
this happens
in the ultra nationalist Camp I think
for me like the peak of that you
survived the internet Modern Warfare two
not not the no Russian scene the scene
where you're the astronaut in space who
gets when the price is hell right now
yeah
EMP that like takes out all of like
let's move America is like just
everything but it um the Shockwave like
destroys a satellite that like an
astronaut's working on and he gets oh
yeah yeah and that was the moment where
I'm like all right
also so
AP moves around forever
so uh best Mohawk in gaming yeah well
that's good enough you don't see it
though until uh till two oh that's a
good point because uh the tubes when
you're playing as other people so I see
people asking are you giving out codes
no we do not have codes to go out I'm
sorry uh you can join us in marveling at
the updated graphics and enjoy
jean-lutes uh def play through here oh
don't say that on PS4 he will never die
he's such an excellent player that we
will uh there's no way anything bad will
happen while he's playing he's gonna be
just Flawless and amazing I mean I heard
him say before we started he's the
world's greatest Call of Duty player
later we're gonna do the um uh what is
it the what's the end level the with the
airplane oh I don't know the name of the
mission what um I mean the one where you
get nuked I think we will make it that
far no no no no no
president on an airplane at the end and
there is a brutally uh hard achievement
it's Infamous called mile high club
where you have to do it on the hardest
difficulty and I believe you have like a
minute before a minute to do it and it's
insanely hard what difficult
best Call of Duty player in the world
you hear this guys
uh no it wasn't fun though as well okay
what was that okay sure that works why
not Shooters on the highest level kind
of become a puzzle game almost because
you really have to fight for every inch
and preserve everything puzzle game
though oh no it's kind of tedious this
game is this game has like enemy closets
where unless you move up to certain
points on the game
to trigger things enemies will just
infinitely be coming out of you so
you're hunkered down on the hardest
difficulty where one bullet will kill
you and you're watching like dudes like
40 dudes infinitely come out of this
closet that's just not possible yeah and
it's just really frustrating actually at
certain points
we're definitely guilty of like the
infinite spawn bad guys
Pride I guess
I guess have fun doing it it
you know whatever I was in high school I
had free time I see a few people chiming
in by the receivers just if you're just
joining us this guy is uh welcoming us
to the Wilderness so we are oh my god
um yes we're playing the uh Call of Duty
uh Modern Warfare remaster uh it is
actually not available for another
couple days it will be publicly
available on October 5th the time
depends on your region
um the way you can play it is if you
digitally pre-purchase infinite Warfare
which comes out November 4th
um and I and I do mean pre-purchase not
pre-order you do actually have to give
them money and then at that point you'll
be able to download and play the
remaster immediately October 5th uh
prior to infinite Warfare launching next
month you can also wait buy infinite
Warfare on disk but if you buy the on
disk version you have to have the disk
in your system in order to play Modern
Warfare remaster so keep all of that in
mind it really seems to be intended as a
just pre-order bonus is something to
reward players for buying the next game
as opposed to being its own standard
product so if you want to play the game
you have to purchase infinite Warfare
currently that's the only way to get it
so just so you know
but it is looking pretty nice
all right now you guys soon
now you're gonna be great you're totally
not gonna blow it
got him nice I don't know why
I have to go down for no real reason but
uh it worked out everything worked out
things are blowing up
that was the other thing that was always
so impressive about this campaign and it
is just like the word is so overused but
cinematic right there's just stuff
happening around you at all times this
thing's blowing up there's a ton of the
characters on stage rushing at you it's
just like impressed almost overwhelming
I remember feeling of roaming at the
time
cop just count Ing and it's an idea
that's been Borrowed by a lot of
Shooters since then like the idea of
making the battlefield feel alive feel
like there's chaos happening around you
feel like you're participating in
something bigger than just like one man
versus the world
they have those big moments where you're
in the middle of the war and you feel
like a you're a subdued kind of in this
huge battle but then they have moments
like I'll give it up where it's like oh
I'm like a special ops doing some
attackers yeah definitely Mission
variety was another big thing about this
game that was so great
and a lesson that I I actually wish more
Shooters would learn
I feel like there are a lot of Shooters
where you are kind of just traveling
down a series of corridors and there's
very little to break that up or attempts
to break that up just don't really land
um but again this game seems to do that
very well every Mission I think we're
gonna start the mission oh yeah this
Mission there's so much of that
I realize we're keeping a lot of Praise
on Modern Warfare but honestly like man
this game is great I'm very excited I'm
very excited to play the remastered are
you Modern Warfare one or two which one
do you think is better because I I feel
like people are pretty good on that one
that yeah hey people in the comments
weigh in Modern Warfare one Modern
Warfare two I'm curious I think we can
all agree that that the top game is
probably not modern warfare three like
it's a fine game but I would say one or
two three Call of Duty finally I just
was like all right I think I'm done to
be honest I think my favorite of the
like modern era of Call of Duty is
actually the original Black Ops I love
yeah so when I when I hear people say
which is the people Call of Duty either
it's Modern Warfare on worker 2 or Black
Ops I think is what people I think I'd
have to say I'm a Black Ops fan you're
going to see other people weigh in I
think maybe two honestly I think my work
for two was the one I played the most
seeing a lot of votes for both one and
two actually a launcher
yeah it's like dead split people are
like it's one and two down the line no
Black Ops fans with me
it's funny how split those are I'm
seeing a lot of people saying Modern
Warfare 2 for multiplayer which I would
actually agree with I think it made some
really smart adjustments also to me too
had more memorable Maps like I like or
at least maybe I just maybe I just
played more Modern Warfare I definitely
played more multiplayer for two yeah
um
for me though it's just a whole package
like the campaign dude somebody said
ghost is the best man I don't remember
ghosts at all
people consider ghost to be one of the
worst so that guy's just that guy might
just be trolling maybe he loves it
though listen you love what you love man
to you
good for you man
where's everybody good yeah you're not
killing enough people stop there you go
everyone issues with these dude RBG you
gotta pick up the RPG
do it
for the stream low things really there
are no Rockets
I just fired it okay we're screwing yep
okay we'll find let me get my gun back
all right all right there we go like I'm
not gonna give up like look at these I
got the sniper with like 84 I'm not
coming out yeah no no you shouldn't you
shouldn't but come on two's gonna pass
up an RPG
where'd everyone go I am you're supposed
to provide sniper support blah blah blah
oh okay yeah yeah
let's all huddle together and snipe from
the same point
get very far you know what if it works
rocket launcher I know man you had that
one rocket could have used it
up that tank
you got the skin I believe in you there
you go
that guy didn't eat his legs
you get shot with any sniper ball I feel
like you're down but if you're not dead
you're down I saw one person vote for
Titanfall it's like modern warfare one
Modern Warfare two Black Ops one guy
Titanfalls like wow now
well it's also not a Call of Duty game
I don't think it qualifies for the best
Call of Duty mode
I wasn't actually got to play a lot of
Titanfall recently Titanfall 2 uh the
campaign's shaping up pretty well I
really enjoyed what I played there's a
lot of unexpected stuff there are whole
sections that are basically like kind of
like Mirror's Edge just for a minute of
like hey here's this really tricky
parkour section can you wall jump three
times in succession and not fall down a
Chasm go like it's actually using the
pilot skills in in a new and interesting
way and then of course you get to like
smash stuff with smex so you know
is pretty good
I wish we knew a little bit more about
infinite Warfare I feel like they
actually haven't been super forthcoming
with like I I haven't personally seen a
demo of that game I don't know if
anybody on staff has seen that game
really recently
um I mean it's out in a month exactly
exactly a month from Tomorrow
doesn't show that much though I guess
they have like here's our studio player
moment here's our multiplayer reveal and
then the game comes out and it's like
that's all they need kindness yeah
loud noises
so guys we've got to reach that house
before anything happens to the
involvement let's go there's one one
thing is uh these scripted moments
always like if you're not standing in
the right spot the guys just like start
pushing you
do it yeah I can definitely get a little
awkward
which is kind of the risk with scripting
moments like that obviously if you start
to ignore what the game tells you to do
things get real weird sometimes
somebody's gonna be yelling about
Battlefield which is fair Battlefield 1
looks good I'm excited
like I consider myself a reasonable man
I
never been one of those like Call of
Duty versus battlefield people in the
sense that I feel like
one has to be awful and one has to be
good because they're so different you
can have your preference for sure
see one person repeatedly saying Pokemon
is the best Call of Duty game which is a
very interesting Theory I would be
curious to hear more I would I would
read that man's blog post
okay don't think about it
I will not
I'll give it as much time as it deserves
which is none
[Music]
uh the watermelon yeah exploded
explodable fruit watermelon would
explode quite that way
yeah that was really that looked great
man remastered wallet watermelon that's
oh they spent a lot of time they had one
guy he was hired guy he was the fruit
guy find all the fruit make it look good
oh come on even surrendering I know but
we're cowering I don't know who's
surrendering necessarily but
[Music]
I stay in the building
yeah actually I did that quite a few
times playing through the very first
time I remember shooting
Squad mates pretty consistently they
give you a little leaning and see though
I think you can kill them and then you
lose the mission like a shoot price or
something like that okay
turn on subtitles oh good call
sorry about that yeah that's usually I
always try and like think of that ahead
of time nope there we go now they don't
have to listen to us they can just mute
us
you do miss out on the gun sound effects
though which are crisp and punchy
sounded very good I would guess actually
that they they probably
um used some of the audio from more
recent Call of Duty games and put it
back into this one I I would suspect I
wonder about that I would suspect they
didn't like record entirely new audio
just for the remaster but they've come
such a long way and have created so many
Call of Duties since this one came out I
feel like it would make a lot of sense
for them to kind of reuse existing
assets that are now better than what
they had available at the time
um and and to put that into this game
man that guy had no idea you were there
yeah oh night vision's fun I remember
there's a one mission in particular
where everyone's just got
is that your guy in the window or okay
yeah yeah
there's one Mission particular you turn
it on it was just like laser sights
everywhere and I remember being like
whoa that looks really rad
enemy intel
that'll be the rest of the stream just
collecting Intel that's all we're gonna
do
did I get every achievement from Modern
Warfare I'm trying to think if I did
because if I beat the game on veteran
I must have gotten everything
I can't think of what I would have
missed because they didn't have any
multiplayer
oh don't die I always respect it about
Call of Duty was uh
they never put in multiplayer
achievements which like Halo was like
terrible I tried to get every
achievement in the Halo 3 and there were
a couple that were impossible because
you had to just wait for it to show up
in the rotation yeah and it would just
never show up or if they show up and
then you wouldn't get it you'd be like
now I have to wait again yeah you can
play obey and only have it pop up once
and that was just so horrible
someone's saying we missed a scripted uh
knife kill by Price which oh was there
there probably is there's a lot of stuff
that's easy to miss if you're not paying
attention and I guess that's actually
kind of a daring design choice in a way
as well
um to include stuff that players may or
may not actually see just to have it
happen anyway it's kind of cool to like
not force players perspective not to
like remove their control and direct the
camera towards the scripted moment just
to have it happen it's really cool
[Music]
to allow players to see that stuff but
not like how do you let them see that
stuff without taking away from them yeah
is that something valve when someone
spends a lot of time talking about if
you've ever listened to me
a few hours
they ever take away camera control from
you right it's like how do we get you to
see this thing and they use all these
like audio and visual tricks to do it I
find that stuff fascinating you almost
have to have like
a psychological perspective on it how
can we what if there's gonna be thinking
about our one hour U.S Paul Jackson
doomed Paul Jackson little does he know
this is me your one and only Call of
Duty game Paul make the most of it
Call of Duty
the only recurring characters called
these ever had was price
in a building at the West End of This
Town
yeah Alex Mason I was gonna say like
Mason yeah those are um oh and then the
numbers what do they mean and then and
then the one guy the other guy from um
yeah but spoilers by the way guys we're
like spoiling every Call of Duty that's
ever happened Sorry by the way I think
uh well the words
he shoots about a helicopter here man oh
you can yeah yeah look things up
sorry which one's underrated uh will
that work
it's the one that came out right after
Modern Warfare and it was back to the
world
it's a totally interesting I I think
that Treyarch really found their footing
like I think world of war needed to
happen for them to make Black Ops no no
I agree Black Ops is better but I think
I think one more time has I remember a
lot of people were claiming it yeah
people I mean listen this game was a
pretty hard after fall how do you how do
you make a game that follows Modern
Warfare like regarded as one of the
greatest Shooters of all time you can
actually play World at War
it was just made available last week
nice nice Pro tip thank you
that's what I think about that I was
like ooh
do I want to play that like no because
I'd have to buy and yeah I'm so busy but
that's that's cool yeah you can go play
that
door
reaching preaching clear
yeah not to repeat ourselves completely
but this still looks like remarkably
good
really glad you're on normal because you
would have been dead
I'm not gonna oh where is that where did
that guy come from oh on the ground
wow did he get you in a sidearm jeez
you ruined their lunch man
uh I mean unless they're eating bullets
for breakfast somebody in the comments
is on your side uh Ross Ross Booth cuff
says I love World of War so he's with
you Jean you got one supporter and
nowhere man apparently
oh
come on check there's Intel here there
is I know it I know also I know it's
giving you a hard time earlier John Luke
about uh how you're such a mystical
duper but seriously trying to like pay
attention and have a conversation while
playing a game is actually way harder
than it looks so good job doing as well
as you're doing I say as you almost die
it's gonna be hilarious and ironic
yeah this shocking fortnite member has
much better range than you expect I
think you did
when again in case you're just joining
us we are still playing Call of Duty
Modern Warfare remastered uh which is
available on Wednesday uh the time
depends on the region but it's only
available to those who pre-purchase
infinite Warfare which is actually out
next month November 4th so digitally
purchase top of the game and you'll be
able to play the remaster in a couple
days
or you know keep your fingers crossed
that activism changes its mind about how
they're releasing this and hope that
they put it out as a standalone product
someday which who the hell knows maybe
I can't imagine it won't that's that
would be insane yeah they haven't
announced any plans though
if you want to play the remaster in 2016
there's a pure chance you're gonna have
to buy infinite Warfare
someone just pointed out you have a 420
ammo counts sick Bro I noticed that
once and bring it up
uh I'm not gonna do it we've had some
fun tangents on this show so far porn
parodies weed jokes this is great we're
gonna get fired man it's like a high
school all over again it's just like I'm
playing Call of Duty yeah welcome to
2007 all the themes this is we actually
did this on purpose we need Mountain Dew
and Doritos
you're not that old
you're younger than I am so 2007 I was a
freshman in high school okay that's
that's the time to be like really into
Call of Duty for sure
which is same same deal yeah I don't
remember the exact age but
it seems young but even then I was like
you know being 14 I'm still like ah see
Paradigm well then but here I died on
purpose because I want to get some of
those sweet right quotes did they stop
doing that incoming Flyers did they
still do that I don't think so but that
yeah I think Modern Warfare 1 and 2 both
did it though so the ones that are
unknown quotes about war
you are in a murder alley right now yeah
oh incoming grenade run there you go
you're good okay hang out here for a
minute
nice
please just go knife everyone else in
the rest of this level
that's nice about normal you can kind of
get away with the run and knife tactics
that guy had lots of rockets on his back
that was unnecessary
oh yeah chat what's Chad dude
so uh yeah talking about modern warfare
three
game I saw a few little earlier people
were saying that they should remaster uh
Modern Warfare 2 which I imagine could
totally happen I mean there's no reason
it couldn't
um I would suspect that it depends on
the success of this promotion like how
well received this remaster is and if it
does seem to
encourage people to buy infinite Warfare
I if it succeeds I see no reason why
they wouldn't do the same thing next
year or in a couple years for Modern
Warfare 2.
um clearly remasters are here to stay
it's something that's become a staple of
the industry at this point a little off
tangent but uh related do you think
they'll do a uh Halo 3 remaster next
year because they've been doing every 10
years every 10 anniversary for Halo one
and two they did it do you think they'll
do it for three I mean then listen you
just noticed a really interesting
pattern I wouldn't be totally surprised
um although that was you know that was a
360 game so it's entirely possible that
that will just yeah but that game to
play like backwards compatible right so
I don't need maybe maybe it will I don't
know that game at the time though
because it was an early 360 game like by
the end of that cycle I mean both uh
reach and Halo uh four looks so much
better like it wasn't even
it was like insane that they were on the
same system how much better those look
so yeah I would like to see a pretty
remastered person I remember three
looking really good three times three is
my favorite no three look good at the
time but actually so you know came out
the same time as this game and I
remember Modern Warfare
gonna be like I think you gotta make a
break for it yeah
introvert some of those buildings
by the way in case you're joining us and
you missed it we are currently playing
on PS4 uh normal difficulty
just so you know
no particular platform preference nice
grenade oh that's fine he's fine oh he's
totally he got right back up no big just
walk that grenade right off that guy's
not fine
oh nice because that guy was totally
gonna launch a rocket here
these environments look great I love the
uh the depth and the detail that AI was
not real smart though oh he just came
walking right at you
I was gonna say no particular platform
preference we just happen to get access
on PS4 so that's what we're playing uh
we're playing it a couple days early uh
if you pre-purchase infinite Warfare you
can play in a couple days
at least a single player
[Music]
let's see
I'm a chat people are really enjoying
the Danny O'Dwyer emote on Twitch we
have a Daniel Dwyer we do we have like
his little like cartoon
get rid of that email it doesn't work
here anymore
but he'll live on in our hearts
or just like add wings to it now doing
his own thing is no clip if you're also
if you're on Twitch you can go find
Danny's Channel doing cool stuff on his
own
yeah
are we allowed to pimp can we connect
Danny I would do too much but you know
give him a shout out yeah he was playing
a VR game where he was like shooting
Nazis uh on the Vive and it looked it
was really funny it was a good video
people do love shooting Nazis we've done
it a lot in many video games
grenade
oh that guy's running the wrong way
[Music]
how big is the download size good
question uh it was just under 40 gigs so
like a pretty sizable I mean clearly
they they must have done something with
the remaster because that is a much
larger file than I would have expected
um so yeah just just the remaster no
infinite Warfare included was 40K
just just shy of 40 kids oh hey
okay
you're running away from the objective
but also I guess from the grenade as
well fair enough I noticed as you were
running like oh wait there's your
grenade
nope I don't think so
where do I can't jump can't open doors
shoot and run
I think it's go round
remember always okay that way maybe this
way yeah okay yeah here we go so I was
going the right way
yeah this right what's on the TV station
and it's infinitely spawning enemies so
just make your way through as quick as
you can because they never stop this is
the one it's annoying in particular on
veteran that I was
I wanted to die yeah it sucks just get
through I didn't want to die in the game
but as quickly as you can right in real
life
it's a sweet release of death we're well
on our way
start dying the moment you're going guys
just run and Gun Man
there's a one room in particular I
remember yeah when it opens up in like
the main like editorial pit totally and
there's just a bunch of desks in a big
circular room yes yes awful not a fan
but at least our misery will look good
and sound good
good made that's gonna get a couple guys
okay I hope so uh
boom Oh that was nice
okay yeah this room your servicing is so
messed up this room right here yeah just
make it out you're 50 meters from the uh
and I think you can just go through the
door I don't think anybody has to open
the door this door right here I would
just have to Camp here
for like 20 30 minutes
full
thankfully we are not currently playing
veterans and yeah you just have to like
book it to this one behind you well you
have to you'd have to book it to a room
like this pray you don't get shot bunker
down here and then you'd have to just
keep doing that and it was oh man it was
not fun yeah you notice how as soon as
you cross the threshold of that last
door suddenly people responding into the
room
no no that's as much as I I love this
game as much as I will you know
compliment it over and over there are
certain things that are updated and this
room this area isn't one of them
that rocket was nice
the post death rocket
yeah someone in the comments agrees this
is the worst mission on veteran you were
absolutely right
a flashbangs a flashbang this
and plays for flashbangs again someone
in the comments recommending flashbangs
good call I remember how you switch
you probably don't put that a claymore
don't think that would help
I think that was a regular frag is it
the uh directional directional pad let's
try and now I honestly remember either
just don't die as much you'll be fine
oh guys
the shadowy glass there's something so
satisfying about shooting someone like
through cover
totally
I'm just gonna keep asking a question to
make you talk to me while you're
concentrating on this movie
no I'm gonna I'm gonna try to refine it
let's see remember how uh
got really weird and cynical yeah like
well it was kind of a dark game man
going back to the whole like kind of
being cynical about America like I
remember like Modern Warfare 2 had like
Dick Cheney books like that's the level
they were at
that sounds weird yeah sorry I'm like
reading the chat
uh you try not to die I'll ReChat
teamwork mostly people being mean about
me why you gotta be like that
it's mostly about you dying it's over
here listen guys it happens
I also haven't played a Call of Duty
game in years yeah I think the last one
I played was
nope that was Ramirez that was your guy
he may have killed him
fine if it's in a constellation I'm
pretty confident this is the mission
that ends with the nuke so you're all
dreamed anyway no it's a couple yeah
it's a little bit so
stupid yeah I think so Nico a couple
more a couple more submissions yeah but
like before the nuke yeah uh before the
new after the nuke it's pretty much
pretty much so yeah
we'll find out again it's been it's been
nine years like I believe I've actually
played the campaign for this since since
it came out I played a bunch of
multiplayer but then um Modern War for
two couple years later where's everyone
that kind of took over
they're everywhere dude just get out of
this room they will continue to spawn go
go go I'm trying to remember towards the
objective
I thought I did though and then I think
I have to clear them out
because yeah you have to like go through
this door or something like dude
I think if you head to the right I think
you can get out no clear yes
but you got to go through the room to
get them to stop spawning because if you
just hang out in that door they won't
spawn forever really annoying yep all
right I was right
oh this is a pain too I forgot there's
like a yeah
that was yeah he said that in the most
Matthew McConaughey way possible
no sign of other side sir people asking
if it's uh just single player or
multiplayer multiplayer will be
available but I believe this Wednesday
is uh only single player will be
available I'll need to double check that
but I'm fairly confident it gets away
from the nuke and then he joins so
oh that's right he's with you guys I
actually don't know that I ever realized
that Griggs was with you on this Mission
great yeah Griggs is with uh Jackson and
then he goes with and teams up to so
because at the end it's like a Joint
Task driver right objective once they
figure out what's actually going on and
then everyone dies
yeah spoiler
should I just like get that one guy it
seems like a bit of a waste but uh hey
why not
chat I don't need this for anything
important
I mean it was probably there for a
reason but oh well
fine
pretty safe bet that if you're in a Call
of Duty game you're gonna die it's so
sad like you watch him get executed oh
God that's right you're all in there and
you watch like Griggs get shot you watch
like yeah I forgot about that whole
thing oh man this is brutal oh I guess
that's something you think you think
soap's the only one alive and then in
two you find out the price is still on
yeah in the reverse Rock Machine
are those friendly Choppers I think they
are right got it yeah they're your guys
yeah okay yeah that was fine they're not
shooting oh yeah I'm not killing you
right now so
foreign
that's fine
uh some people are mad we're just
spoiling everything
yeah but this game is nearly a decade
it's a decade old
I feel like and we haven't spoiled any
um Black Ops stuff I think we've mainly
just spoiled Modern Warfare ones I just
wanted to
primarily we vaguely mentioned some
other stuff but whatever man this is
like a Nostalgia Fest
apologies if we genuinely destroyed the
story for you but man come on these
this game has been out for a while
I think he's in there I hear him
do it oh yeah
he's not
clear clear
good thing we turn the subtitles on
all this hot
dialogue
okay I thought he was saying yeah to be
shooting it that was pretty amazing
timing
no sign of Al Assad the broadcast is a
recording over yeah
Roger that command out also this game's
credit score
there's a rap tone yeah let's go I
remember that uh iced tea is like one of
the voices and oh no that was gears like
iced tea and Body Count did his custom
song for Gears Ice Cube though
was in one of the Call of Duties he was
like the he was a multiplayer like
announcer he'd be like he'd be like yeah
he's like death man shouldn't be like
all right it was an ice cube or was it
iced tea or iced tea or Ice Cube It's
one of them you tell me man
I do remember there when Modern Warfare
freaking out because remember he sold
the um
line of ice tea buying his questions
Edition him wearing the night vision
goggles
I see somebody saying oh I didn't know
this game is already out so yeah we're
nearly we're about probably gonna wrap
up pretty soon we generally assume for
about an hour uh but in case you missed
the intro you missed me mentioning it
see I told you we're gonna say that for
like every Mission this was because
they're pretty much all good
oh I remember that yeah
and again like I remember being kind of
Blown Away by how much is Just happening
around you in this Mission League you
are participating in a much bigger
battle this is the part I was talking
about with the night vision model where
you can just see all the laser dots
available on October 5th the exact
unlock time for the download depends a
new region so you're gonna have to check
and figure out what time is for your
specific area
um but yeah if you if you pre-purchase
the um the digital Legacy digital Pro or
digital deluxe edition of infinite
Warfare right there you will be able to
unlock wow that's a lot of science oh I
remember that so loud Rave was a weird
thing to remember and be fun that's a
very specific memory
fun laser settings oh yes we're playing
we have Early Access we're a couple days
early but you can play on the fifth if
you pre-purchase uh the next Call of
Duty game which is out November 4th but
this remaster is available October 5th
if you purchase the full game yep we're
gonna play for a couple more minutes
here yeah currently on PS4 currently
playing on normal
currently marveling at the laser sights
I mean in my opinion looks and sounds
pretty good it's been it's been pretty
fun to kind of relive this and have it
actually like live up to my my memory of
the campaign
[Applause]
you have to wait for them to move their
laser sights
yeah they actually can show you
my guess is yes apparently uh it's
finished downloading all right
sure well we weren't gonna make it to
the end anyway so it wouldn't have
really affected us but I didn't I didn't
know it was okay that was weird
see what else is going on in chat
foreign
and see how far you get in the next
mission come on that'll be a great time
for everybody
just started
yeah but the mission's very pretty
drastically in mind because some of them
are actually for the board
there was a map like around this kind of
area
that's not gonna be wrong no I mean most
of the multiplayer maps Drew art assets
from single player levels and like
rearrange them but yeah it was mostly
set in similar areas
I'll just be blasting the multiplayer
mode will be available but currently
it's we're just playing single player um
single players what's going to be
available on the fifth multiplayer to
follow shortly thereafter
um there's gonna be 10 Maps available at
launch like the launch of infinite
Warfare on November 4th they will add
the final six Maps remastered maps from
the original Modern Warfare before the
end of the year for free uh this is part
of the bonus
um and no word if it will be available
as an independent product at any point
but we kind of hope it will
[Music]
thank you
let's see here
also other notable remasters coming out
Skyrim still happening right pretty
psyched for Skyrim I'm sure we'll do one
of these for Skyrim uh I believe it's
end of November so that was a little bit
further off but that one is a completely
sandal and thing it's not tied to any
new game that's coming out the way that
Modern Warfare is oh the Skyrim remaster
is purely its own thing oh no
uh is that actually we want to cut it
maybe you straight too far from the Sun
I give one more try give one more try
we're trying to go a little bit yeah
getting in a death like that
it's an anti-climatic way to end it you
are in the middle of a bunch of nades
fan though yeah
I mean
it's not really a cover shooter but
cover is a smart plan right now created
[Music]
nice nice good at that point reach
oh who's got Rockets I think there's
somebody behind you not these guys whoa
blow some stuff up
[Music]
people are asking if it really looks
that much better and they say it still
looks the same I mean honestly we are
working on this side by side comparison
video I'm fairly certain so you can have
a look at what the game used to look
like and what it looks like now
um I guarantee your memory makes it look
better than it actually worked I mean I
think we're all prone to thinking things
we're actually much nicer looking than
they were
um so in my mind this looks a lot better
than these two that's oh that's really
cool
in my mind this looks pretty darn good
this is really good to me this looks
like a game that could have easily come
out within just the past couple years as
opposed to the game between like nine
years ago like it actually did
but of course it's kind of subjective
it's you know it's what you're hoping to
get out of it I mean nothing else to me
it's a good excuse to go back and play
this like I'm I'm excited to go play
through this campaign it's a really
excellent campaign
and I'm excited to see you know how
multiplayer Works how populated the
servers are go back play a lot of those
classic Maps again I mean this was the
game that kind of really popularized the
idea of progression and XP in
multiplayer and it'll be really cool to
go back and see what that looked like in
those early stages
all right we're glad you got to blow
some stuff up yeah this might be a good
place to end because I think there's
still quite a bit of mission ahead but
if you guys want to check out Call of
Duty remastered uh it's available
publicly on October 5th for those who
pre-purchase infinite Warfare which is
out November 4th
um you can also gain access to the game
if you just buy infinite Warfare on disk
but for that you'll have to wait a month
and you'll have to keep the infinite
Warfare disc in the machine while you're
playing the Modern Warfare remaster in
order for the remaster to run keep all
that in mind a little complicated like I
said fingers crossed and maybe they'll
release it as a standalone product today
we have no word like there's no reason
to believe officially that that will
happen but it seems like it would make a
lot of sense so hopefully it happens um
but yeah we hope you guys enjoyed
watching us or really John Luke tear
through some of those early levels got a
sense of what the game looks like how it
sounds
um yeah Jean Luke any closing thoughts
I think it looks great it's I'm still
remember how to play it it's like riding
a bike I thought I would maybe be except
for throwing flash bangs that part I
don't remember how to do that but that's
a little that's some Advanced bike
tricks right there to be honest I always
just go for damage anyway I just I throw
you know frags and shoot people that was
really cool I would absolutely play this
again if
I knew how to get it easily without it's
five minute warfare that's basically
what it boils down to I guess so if
you're gonna buy infinite Warfare that
will depending regardless of which
version you buy if you're buying that
game it will grant you access to the
moderation remaster I might end up doing
that I was kind of interested in
infinite Warfare anyway yeah space dog
fights all right yeah that could be cool
we'll see I mean they know what they're
doing Call of Duty games are
consistently like polished well-crafted
games you you can be sick of the series
if you want but they're consistently
like pretty well made games so we'll see
we're obviously gonna have a full review
of that next month so if you stay tuned
to gamespot.com there'll be more
coverage of all things Call of Duty
um and keep an eye out for a graphics
comparison video of the remastered
Modern Warfare compared to the original
Modern Warfare along with a ton of other
content so yeah stay tuned to
gamespot.com for everything Call of Duty
and everything video games
I've hit in the outro very
yay